Harvey Weinstein the once-powerful
Hollywood producer is wearing a monitor
and is out on a million dollars bail
this morning it was the moment the me to
movement had been waiting for Weinstein
surrendered to police here in New York
on Friday and was charged with rape and
criminal sex act charges they stem from
alleged assaults against two women in
2004 and 2013 in all more than 80 women
have accused him of sexual misconduct
DeMarco Morgan has the latest DeMarco
good morning Anthony good morning
Weinstein found himself in handcuffs
following a month-long investigation by
the Manhattan district attorney's office
and the NYPD prosecutors thank the
survivors who came forward and urged
additional survivors to reach out to
investigators the disgraced Hollywood
executive ignored the lights cameras and
questions as he walked into New York
City's first precinct while inside the
66 year old sat in a jail cell for a
half hour while his paperwork was
processed Weinstein emerged in handcuffs
before being escorted to court to hear
the charges two counts of rape and one
count of a criminal sexual act
money and power one of the charges stems
from an alleged 2004 incident involving
Lucia Evans she told The New Yorker that
when she was an aspiring actress
Weinstein forced her to perform oral sex
on him at his Manhattan office the
second charge is connected to an
anonymous woman who alleges Weinstein
raped her in a New York City hotel in
2013
Weinstein attorney Benjamin Bratton said
his client posted a 1 million dollar
bail and agreed to turn over his
passport people get convicted only when
there is credible evidence beyond a
reasonable doubt and in this case I do
not believe that the district attorney
has that nor do I believe that mr.
Weinstein has intentionally violated the
law I'm so proud of all the women that
came forward bravely and told their
stories TV reporter Lauren Sivan says in
2007 Weinstein trapped her in a hallway
and masturbated in front of her she
hopes Weinstein will eventually face
jail time I take solace in the fact that
he will never be remembered for any of
his oscar-winning movies he will never
be remembered for any of the careers he
helped launch he will be remembered as a
predator a sexual predator and that
actually fills me with joy
now again Harvey Weinstein was fitted
with a GPS tracking device and told not
to leave New York or Connecticut without
the court's permission if convicted he
could face up to 25 years in prison and
the grand jury in this case is still
working some more charges may be coming
Jana
DeMarco Morgan thank you